this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 21 with Echo and me Jocko
and
we had a
an event take place a couple a week ago
I guess
the A guy by the name of Jim searlesly
he was on podcast 200
um just an awesome guy
he was a Vietnam veteran he was severely
wounded in in 1969 about a month before
he was done with his tour in Vietnam he
ended up
as a triple amputee and
lost both of his legs and lost one of
his arms
and he just died he just died on on May
30th it's uh 2021 right now
and it obviously horrible was it was
unexpected
um
but his story
when he came on the podcast and what he
lived through
there was some some layers to it
um when he'd come home from Vietnam with
this you know triple amputee
who went to rehab for nine months and
you know he learned all the things that
you have to learn when you lose both
your legs and one arm how you know how
are you going to get by what are you
going to do what do you do to get around
the house how to use a wheelchair an
electric wheelchair a regular wheelchair
how you're going to get in and out of
that thing what you need to be careful
of what you got to do to keep yourself
as healthy as you can
and he went to that thing for nine
months
and he then he carried on and he carried
on with his life he he started a roofing
company he went to college he started
doing real estate he ended up being the
the national commander of the disabled
American veterans you know later in his
life but he he basically just carried on
and just an amazing
an amazing human an amazing person and
and obviously hugely inspirational for
anybody
because he's doing all that and he's
doing it with these with as a as a guy
with one arm
and
it was interesting because when we got
done with that podcast we were we we
ended up sitting around and talking for
a while and one of the things that he
brought up
was he said have you ever heard of a guy
named Lewis polar and
he he obviously hadn't listened to the
fact that
um we had done a podcast about Chastity
puller the most iconic Marine of all
time and then we did a podcast about
Lewis polar his son
who was
also wounded in Vietnam severely wounded
in Vietnam he lost both of his legs he
had massive Damage Done To His Hands
Lewis puller did this is Jesse puller's
son
and he came home
and eventually
some well in 1993 Lewis polar
Jr killed himself
and and he wrote an incredible book and
we covered the book on the podcast
on podcast 122. the the book is called
Fortunate Son
and so with that background which which
Jim certainly didn't know he says have
you ever heard of a guy named Louis
puller and I said yes sir absolutely I I
have we did a podcast on him I know
about him
and he said you know I was in rehab
with Lewis polar
which was obviously very I mean a very
interesting connection
that
he was he knew him
and then he made this point Jim sorely
made this point
that
he said Lewis puller
never accepted a hundred percent
in his heart what had happened to him
he said he look he he accepted at 98
maybe 99 but he never accepted 100 what
had happened and never
never accepted that reality and moved on
with it
and he said and that's what that's what
killed him
is
we we have to be able to accept reality
and look I'm not saying I could do it
I'm not making that claim
I mean I'm saying Jim searlesy did it
and he said he did it and he's saying
that Lewis polar Jr didn't do it
but we have to at least try and do that
you know I we did one of these
a little time ago where I was talking
about the fact that um you know
everybody's a little bit insane right
everybody's a little bit crazy because
we all paint our own reality Because the
actual definition the clinical
definition of someone that's is insane
is someone that doesn't their reality
doesn't match
actual reality well guess what we all
have different varying levels of what
reality is
some of us are pretty close
some of us are a little further up when
you meet someone that's
they think they're in a better situation
than they're in or they think they're in
a worse situation they're like their
reality isn't quite matched up and it
goes all the way from people that are
really closely aligned to what reality
is that's I I think probably the best
place to be to people that are
definition by the definition of insane
where their reality is totally different
from actual reality
but you know you meet some people that
are like oh I'm gonna
uh you're uh I'm gonna be uh I'm gonna
be uh a football player
and you're like um
you know like the reality isn't there
you know what I'm saying whatever you
pick you pick a thing that somebody
thinks is happening or they think
someone
they think someone cares about them and
I know they care about me it's like
that's not really the reality and
they're just not there right they're not
insane they're not over on the far side
of the spectrum where the reality
totally doesn't match but you can tell
it's off a little bit
so we have the possibility of doing that
as well when it comes to accepting
reality
and accepting where we're at a hundred
percent and accepting things the way
they unfolded 100 and again I'm not
trying to say I could do this I have no
idea I've never been in a situation like
that
but I'm gonna say
that we do have to look around I've
never been in that extreme situation but
I've been in some tough situations
when you get in those tough situations
it doesn't help
to keep that little two percent three
percent four percent one percent that's
different from reality doesn't help
that little thing will eat away at you
when you wish that this wouldn't happen
or you wish you would have made a
different decision you complain about it
you blame you know other people you
blame the circumstances and you get
eaten up by that stuff
stop doing that
stop doing that it's not it's not
beneficial to you
it's not beneficial to me this is a this
is really a tenant of of extreme
ownership right
I know I can't control everything but I
can control how I respond to it
I know bad things happened and I could
sit there and blame other people I could
wish that it didn't win a different way
I could wish that it would have never
happened I could wish I would have made
a different decision all those things
don't do that
stop wishing stop complaining stop
blaming instead be like Jim Searles the
uh a freaking hero
and start doing
start making things happen
with that
let's get in some q a I guess
so it's a rough subject
first question
I'm a seventh grade English teacher in
Virginia and things are not bad in the
classroom but it's my first year
teaching and I definitely have a lot to
learn
I have one class in particular that's
almost all boys and started this year
out Rowdy and I've made great strides in
learning when it's appropriate to be
energetic and when they need to be when
they need to respect others and their
right to an education
but some but some days one or another of
them will really be feeling his oats
and the others tend to feed on that I
struggle to rein this in with that harsh
tone and a demand but it has to stop
so that their classmates
can learn
do you and Echo have any advice for
leadership applied to 12 and 13 year old
kids I know you're both parents so I'd
be interested in your your insights here
yeah
cool question and I got some ideas about
it and these are all kind of ideas that
I've used at various points in various
situations with both my own kids with
sealed platoons
um number one
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email
us at Jocko underground.com and we'll
get you taken care of until then we will
see you mobilized
Underground